un double monde une double époque la
maison triolet aragon présente deux
artistes dans une exposition de partie
des oeuvres croisées d'abord celle d'une
collaboration de plus de 20 ans niki de
saint phalle disparu en 2002 et
pierre-marie le jeune tien marie lejeune
avait travaillé en tant qu'assistante
que niki de saint phalle sur des grands
projets comme la fontaine stravinsky à
paris ou le jardin la toscane qui tenait
à coeur à niki de saint phalle et
en 1999 il avait réalisé quelques
oeuvres ensemble aussi à niki de saint
phalle aimait beaucoup réaliser des
oeuvres d'art 81
des oeuvres qui n'ont pas s'était montré
depuis la disparition de l'artiste
plasticienne franco américaines
auxquelles répondent des oeuvres
personnelles et celles de pierre marie
lejeune toujours en activité le
sculpteur dessinateur travail des formes
géométriques l'acier et les miroirs
ce sont plus des tableaux qu'on retrouve
des tableaux qui sont centrés sur le
sport et qui sont souvent des croquis ou
des tableaux qui allait représenter une
sculpture que pierre marie lejeune aller
après construire ces on a des fois
l'occasion de voir le résultat fini la
sculpture et les collages que pierre
marie lejeune a réalisé un jeu de figure
propres aux deux artistes qui se
réinventer chaque jour un travail
contemporain que nous l'aragon apprécié
[Musique]